everybody's got a question
all right now sky J here we go baby bear
crossing username J wants to know if I
cook my eggs in a pan like that actually
I do cook eggs in a pan very similar to
that but actually my toaster cooks them
forming because I don't really cook so I
kind of just put the egg in the pan and
it magically cooks the egg for me wait
what's this ace in Spanish oh I don't
read the one that's in English okay
awesome Alexa wants to know if everybody
is well I'm gonna tell you about
everybody is and it's this hoodie it's a
hoodie buddy you basically plug your
iPod into your hoodie and you can listen
to music at the same time is that not
pretty much the coolest thing you've
ever seen cuz I ever tried Jones soda
actually haven't used to do one of my
favorite drinks when I was growing up
and probably cream soda would be my
favorite although they actually sent me
once upon a time a customized Jones soda
bottle
my favorite Nintendo game - interesting
yes actually I will be in Tommy Wiseau's
new movie it's actually more like a
short film but if you want to watch it
it's airing on October
October 14th a three o'clock a.m.
Pacific if you guys want to check it out
and if you have no idea who Tommy Wiseau
is I don't know if that's a good or a
bad thing so I'm here with Tommy who we
just got out of your new film here that
you're in how was it acting as the
director and I love it you have to see
it by Cameron B wants to know if I'd
ever go on SNL I think the actual
question there should be would SNL ever
have me on their show because I'm pretty
sure if they asked I would say yes
kidding me vanilla girl wants to know if
I were to design something for a huge
fashion brand what would it be well I'm
not really into fashion so most likely I
would probably design a really sweet
pair of sweatpants Sam wants me to do a
video with my new vacuum now it's kind
of strange requests if you guys don't
know I got a robotic vacuum and it
basically just goes around my apartment
and cleans
and his name is Beiber Tim well she is
asking what happened to I just seen
reviews yeah I've been really slacking
on there but I promise to have a review
up soon for you guys Justin what do I do
in my downtime well now that I got a
Playstation I'm pretty much in front of
my TV and play games what's my favorite
color would I ever visit Canada yes I
would but I actually haven't really had
a reason to come to Canada so if anybody
has a really good reason that I should
come to Canada maybe just leave in the
comments below and maybe I'll come visit
you guys Cheyenne is bored and wants to
know what to do I'm sorry and on these
suggestions maybe you could um like
curse something Dylan wants to know if I
were to go to jail what would it be for
obviously it would be for stealing Steve
Jobs his heart do I like swimming and
not so much because I'm actually really
bad at it so I always opted for finding
some sort of random floatation device to
assist me in my swimming
in case you guys missed it I'm giving
away iPod Touch probably wondering well
how do I get this iPod Touch pretty
simple all you have to do is go to
facebook.com slash iJustine and like my
page if you've already liked it then
you're already entered I'll be giving it
away here in the next few weeks so be
sure to like it because I'll be
announcing the winner there on my page
so yeah that's that and I will see you
guys in the next episode of sky chain
and of course don't forget to subscribe
so you'll know when I launch a more
wonderful videos just like this one